si fue a través del comandante de la
guardia revolucionaria iraní hossein
salami quien dijo que israel pagará un
alto precio por estos ataques sobre gaza
esto durante un encuentro con ciudadana
jala el líder de la yihad islámica que
se encuentra en teherán también se sumó
rusia que pidió la máxima moderación
para todas las partes mismas palabras
usó la unión europea que también expresó
su preocupación por la situación y
defendió la la posibilidad de que israel
defienda a sus ciudadanos pero pidió que
el conflicto no sea más amplio una
consideración que ha recibido críticas
porque en este caso fue israel el que
lanzó el primer ataque sobre la franja y
que promete continuar esta escalada de
violencia porque ya el portavoz de las
fuerzas israelíes advirtió que se
preparan para una operación que podría
durar una semana